bien je vous annonce que monsieur chirac
doit normalement on vient de le dire au
siège du rpr faire une déclaration cet
après midi à 16 heures nous en saurons
plus dans notre journal de 20 heures
près qu'on en vienne maintenant à une
autre déclaration pour être complet dans
ce débat la déclaration qu'a faite hier
soir monsieur georges marchais au nom du
parti communiste monsieur georges
marchais qui se félicitait de cette
victoire nous sommes prêts à assumer au
gouvernement comme à tous les niveaux de
la vie nationale
toutes nos responsabilités
pour que soient mises en oeuvre la
politique nouvelle de plein emploi de
justice et de progrès social de
développement national des sorts des
libertés
d'initiatives en faveur de la paix du
désarmement de la dépendance de la
solution de tous les grands problèmes du
monde
politique dont le pays a besoin
nous pensons que les obstacles les
difficultés sur le chemin du progrès de
l'union de toutes les forces populaires
seront surmontées dès lors que
s'affirmera la volonté d'agir ensemble
au service de cette politique nouvelle
et des réformes démocratiques qu'elle
implique
cette volonté pour notre part nous
l'avons
le changement
absolument besoin pour se réaliser du
parti communiste de soda port original
dynamique et créateurs au mouvement
populaire bien fois qu'on va voir
maintenant il m